the white house vamping up its
communication seemed today as the battle
for the Supreme Court heats up we are
one week away from president Trump
announcing his nominee for the high
court to replace retiring Justice
Anthony Kennedy this as the president
says he interviewed four candidates
today and plans to meet two to three
more Trump is rolling up his sleeves
gearing up for a fierce fight with
Democrats who are vowing to block his
pick it's probably going to be vicious
because the other side all they could do
is obstruct and resist you know the
whole thing is resist but and maybe
someday we'll be able to get along with
the other side I don't know but right
now it's only resist that's all they
want to do is stop things from happening
so they're going to try very hard but I
think it's gonna go actually very
quickly if I picked the right person and
this comes amid growing concerns from
the left that the new makeup of the
court could lead to the reversal of the
Roe versus Wade ruling legalizing
abortion the president also weighing in
on that in his sit-down with Maria
Bartiromo
are you going to ask your nominees
beforehand how they might vote on Roe
vs. Wade well that's a big one and
probably not they're all saying don't do
that you don't do that you shouldn't do
that but I'm putting conservative people
on and I'm very proud of Neal Gorsuch he
has been outstanding his opinions are
you know is so well written so brilliant
and I'm gonna try and do something like
that but I don't think I'm going to be
so specific and the questions I'll be
answering and I'm actually told that I
shouldn't be Maine Republican Susan
Collins a swing voter in the sent in the
Senate vows to oppose a nominee who
would overturn the ruling I believe very
much that Rovi way is settled law as it
has been described by Chief Justice
Roberts a candidate for this important
position who would overturn roe v wade
would not be acceptable to me because
that would indicate and activist agenda
that I don't want to see a
judge have okay so obviously they know
this is a key issue and I've concerned
you know both sides talking about this
but the president in his interview with
Maria Bartiromo
was saying that he wouldn't necessarily
you know ask that specific question it's
not something that he personally is
looking for in a nominee right so
conservatives have said that we we're
not asking for any nominee this is going
back many decades to say specifically
how they would rule on any one issue
what conservatives say that they want is
somebody who will rule based on how they
on the strict reading of the
Constitution's not like interpreting
well maybe the founders could have
thought about something good and they
didn't understand and and this
particular issue of roe v wade is one
where even Ruth Bader Ginsburg I went
back and read today her thoughts about
that actual decision being one that was
probably outside the realm of what the
Constitution was saying and that's what
riled up conservatives about this issue
for a long time is that that decision
itself was one that they would look back
and say that was not decided well now
that doesn't mean it isn't precedent
okay or or some people might call it
settled law or but it so it is going to
be a major sticking issue but go back
and look at it I remember when I was and
I was a spokesperson like Raja the
deputy press secretary is going to move
over and do full time communications for
this nominee I was a spokesperson for
Justice Roberts I just knew roe v wade
kind of based on the general idea of
what I knew growing up but I'd never
gone to law school and I was getting all
these questions about the right to
privacy and I remember going to the
staff secretary at the time who happened
to be Brett Kavanaugh and saying can you
help me understand I thought this was
supposed to be about abortion rights and
everyone's asking me about the right to
privacy and he said it's a great
question let me walk you through it and
that's how I that's when I first
understood how the decision was actually
made I do think there's a lot of
hysteria around it however it doesn't
mean that people don't feel extremely
passionately and of course it's going to
rally up the president's base but we'll
rally up the Liberals base as well and I
think that the president is right and he
will probably be cautious and he will
say this over and over that I'm not
going to ask the nominee how he or she
would rule specifically
on this issue but it will be the
undercurrent of all the fights for the
next several weeks okay mr. Starr Walt
she's she's right oh smart with that
she's right thank you guys for having me
here today happy Independence Day week
yay yay for the record so Quinnipiac
University has a new poll out today that
looks at Americans attitudes on this
issue and guess what overwhelmingly
Americans don't want to see Roe vs. Wade
overturned that's not that's a tube by a
two-to-one margin and even a majority
among men so the hysteria here is it's
damaging because nobody's saying that
the way that abortion the way that
access to elective abortions has been
rolled back in the United States hasn't
been by an effort I'm telling you you're
the lawyer
hasn't been rolled back through big
we're gonna knock it over it's gonna be
kaput instead what's happened is states
have found ways conservative states have
found ways to put different limitations
on access to abortion in Texas in
Alabama there are 20 states or so in
which getting an abortion is almost
impossible it's extremely difficult
where they've met where states have
matched the voters in those places and
done it and none of that has had to do
with overturning roe v wade right it's
had it's been about taking the long
track back conservatives started this 30
and 40 years ago a long track back to
before Roe when how can we make this a
federal issue how can we make this for
the states
how can federalism apply here and that's
what's happening but what you've heard
and what I've read from Jeffrey Toobin
and other people that have said that
african-americans will no longer be
welcome in elite universities than all
of this stuff it's worse even than the
stuff I heard when Robert Bork was the
nominee many many many moons ago and
it's not good for the discussion number
one but number two they're creating
problem for Democrats they create this
monster they say this terrible evil
human being is going to rise up out of
the belly of the swamp and come and ruin
your lives and then this person is gonna
walk out and you know what they're gonna
say he's alright she seems she seems
nice and that's what that happened with
Roberts that what happened with Gore
such these heinous expectations are met
with a nice competent person and people
go okay wow it's interesting yeah
heinous expectations met with a nice
competent person so that sounds a lot
like it's just the rhetorical hype the
vitriol Wan really we've seen in the
past that this type of thing has
happened and then you see in terms of
the person who comes forward like in the
case of Neal gorgeous somebody who has
been you know well respected and admired
and complimented in terms of how he's
converted himself thus far well I could
make the same argument you know going
back to Merrick garland he was well
respected highly rated and never given
the opportunity to have even a hearing
much less a vote but I think the big
point here is that we live in different
times Kimberly I was talking with Abby
Huntsman today on and she said to me she
said she had Justice Scalia son on and
on Fox and Friends and that he said to
her you know his dad was approved 98 to
nothing yep now you think about this 98
to nothing he's a qualified competent
jurist with a long record and a clear
conservative and yet not one so-called
Liberal Democrat voted against Justice
Scalia but in 2018 we live in a
situation that's far different in terms
of how polarized our countries and we
have a far different president so my
colleagues here on this panel say oh but
he could be a nice guy and of course
Neil Gorsuch was a nice guy and don't
worry about it they make they have all
these terrible things my pal Chris tyre
wall comes from DC he says what what's
all this black people won't be in elite
institutions well affirmative action is
a big deal for the Supreme Court and
they set the rules for how schools can
consider young people especially young
people coming from underprivileged
conditions but the larger point to my
thinking is this that what you're
looking at now is approving a fifth
conservative justice in polarized
political times potentially creating a
rubber stamp in the Supreme Court for
real a conservative agenda and people
say well but you know President Trump
says he's not gonna ask about abortion
it's not a litmus test for the
conservatives so let me read you a quote
that comes from Donald Trump he says
that'll happen automatically in my
opinion because I'm putting pro-life
justices on the court it'll go back to
the states and the states then can make
the determination so this is not a
secret to liberals and it's not a secret
to conservatives he wants justices who
will undo roe v-- wade why don't if he
wants to undo but that pro-life or in
the terms of their their viewpoints but
he was pretty specific with Maria saying
that he wasn't going to ask that
question or single at the requirements
verses a constitutionalist that is yeah
that is would actually just uphold the
Constitution and construe and read the
what he said that during the campaign
right correct right so what he said is
I'm going to put I will I will work to
nominate a conservative justices Senator
McConnell has worked to confirm
conservative justices then and and even
if the president never even asked them
what their limit the litmus but it is
also one of the factors that he
campaigns Arnie but he promised to put
justices on the bench like Neal Gorsuch
and that is you know widely lauded by
the Republicans and conservatives that
he put somebody that was in keeping with
his campaign promise time also yes
that's what you want to instead of going
back to what he said during the campaign
look back to Gorsuch looked back to the
way that was handled the president he
has no problem turning up the
temperature on issues but on this issue
I think he approaches things in a fairly
normal establishment kind of a way you
know he's good he's appointing people
that I think most people are he's gonna
appoint people that most people are
comfortable with and he's probably going
to get it passed it's not gonna be 98 to
nothing but he'll probably get it done
and I'm not even concerned by what the
kind of things like that Susan Collins
says the kind of judges that get
appointed now are not the kind of judges
like in the judge Bork days that were
advocates for overturning roe v wade
most of them keep kind of mum on their
personal views on these things and so I
think it's gonna be non-controversial
all right so we shall see this ad one
little thing which is that you know the
left uses the idea of Roe being
overturned as the right uses the idea of
guns being abolished
and it is the way to fire up your bass
neither of those issues are actually on
the table right but that is what people
will use so we can be quite calm about
like the types of judges that are gonna
get out there and how they might rule
but that the spin is going to be what it
is but the forwardable
infrastructure around conservative
nominees I think is really in place
because of how Robert Bork was treated
in the 80s and the Conservatives figured
it out that they are not going to let
this happen to another nominee the
Democrats had to do the same thing for
Elena Kagan and Sotomayor during the
Obama administration and the judicial
confirmations have been a real bright
spot for conservatives with this
administration and so I think that you
know the timing is everything in
politics and President Trump seems to
have great luck when it comes to one
last point on this which is I hear
conservatives say you know Rovi weights
pretty settled Chief Justice Roberts has
says it's pretty settled so stare
decisis which means that you don't
overturn things without cause is going
to hold but what did we see a see from
gorse that you say he's highly praised
Kimberly he came on and I think it's a
week or two ago Chris he just voted to
overturn a 40-year law that would had
regard to how unions were able to
collect so-called agency fees or dues
from people who may disagree with their
political agenda he over target but
there no one saying no one's saying that
these people aren't conservative yes and
these are the kind of justices that any
Republican president would be picking
because this has been as dana says a
40-year project this is the most
important thing to many many many
conservatives is retaking control of the
Supreme Court and they they have not
hidden that and that was one of the main
deciding factors for many of the people
including hoarders eligos a quarter yeah
of them that cast a vote on the ballot
for now President Chomp